[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul and it's time to
bring spoiling king back as we break
down the new cbs series the stand
over the next nine weeks we're going to
be going through every episode of the
show to break down what you need to know
about the plot and it's ending
there will of course be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want anything
ruined then i recommend that you turn
off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
to never miss a breakdown and
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoyed
the first episode as much as we did
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the breakdown
okay so the stand hits a little close to
home in 2020
due to its plot which centers around a
lethal strain of influenza
completely ravaging the world within
99.4
99.4
fatality rate it pretty much wipes out
the majority of human life on the planet
and the story centers around the
survivors battling it out against the
forces of evil
led by a character known as randall
flagg i will be discussing some elements
of the book here
but on the whole i'll not jump too far
ahead so you at least have some
surprises
as we go through this series now we pick
up at a church in boulder colorado
and see the after effects of the disease
firsthand it completely wiped out the
congregation
and not even jesus gave any mercy to the
people that were in the vicinity
this opening differs from the beginning
of the source material
as in that we saw charles campion
leaving the military base
whereas the order sort of gets flipped
around so that we're dropped in at the
deep end
here we join harold's first day as part
of the body disposal unit
and fans of the original work will
likely be thrown off slightly
as things throughout the entry are
ordered quite differently
king has even said that he will be
changing several aspects for the series
and we do know that the ending of the
season will be completely different to
the book
apparently it will show us what happened
to the characters after the events of
the closing chapter
so there's a lot of things to look
forward to even if you're familiar with
the work
this intro really shows us the aspects
that humanity has been left with
and we watch harold vomiting due to the
sight of bodies
this shows us the horror of everything
that's going on
however that doesn't mean it's all doom
and gloom and we catch
another character collecting movies so
that they have something to show
humanity
once it manages to rebuild itself we
also catch a poster of darkman
which i don't know if it was intentional
or not but looks very similar to the
first image that comes
up when you google captain trips sam
raimi who directed the film also cameoed
in the original series
so it does feel like a sort of wink to
that now we can also catch the cover of
expose magazine
which shows tom cruise and the titles
how to make an impression
and how to gain respect someone must
have played them the mission impossible
lickedorio from yesterday because damn
in the middle of a pandemic everyone
seems to love tom cruise
now this view of the past sort of segues
into it and
it's not too long before we take a trip
back five months earlier before the
disease ravaged humanity
we see how the only thing that people
are being warned about on the radio is
fireworks
and it makes me long for the days where
the scariest news reports were talking
about killer clowns on the loose
in this past we see harold spying on his
old babysitter franny goldsmith
and we watch her talking to her father
who's come down with a bad cough
you may also notice the main t-shirt
that he has on and this location is
where king is originally from and a lot
of his work is set
in the source material franny actually
confessed to her father that she was
pregnant before he died
but that plot point is completely absent
in this introduction
which we'll talk about later you also
discover that she had a deaf brother who
died at a young age
and this likely helped to shape the
character that we see
lorna is caught being a peeping tom by
two of his classmates
and he tries to get away from them on
his bike but comes across something that
looks like a dead skunk
this sends him flying over the
handlebars and the pair post what he's
been up to on instagram
ban him run the area and he has to walk
home humiliated
to make matters worse his story soulmate
has been rejected by
cemetery dance publications and a number
of other outlets for being well
let's say not quite right for them we
discover that fran
actually put a nail in his wall the day
he got his first rejection letter
and every time since then he's pinned
them into it showing that he will never
give up writing
or his pursuit for her little fan theory
here
this entire show could actually be
harold's story soulmate in which the
world ends and he and the woman he
fantasizes over are left as the only
people on earth
and naturally they fall in love i'm just
saying yeah
maybe that's the new ending king is
talking about anyway it seems like
everyone other than the immune are
putting on their calling and to work
sick voices
and we watch as pretty much everyone he
comes across as sneezing like
there's no tomorrow which spoiler alert
there probably isn't
now cut to a u.s army research facility
in killeen texas
and we see stu redmond played by james
marsden
stew though he came into contact with
the virus actually
never came down with any symptoms and
thus he's been studied as a guinea pig
alongside some literal guinea pigs hey
i'm the one who does the puns around
here
whilst at his friend's gas station in
our net charles campion a soldier from
the base crashed his car into it
and came into contact with him and his
pals as we heard from the news bulletin
in the prior scene
our net was completely locked down and
put under quarantine in order to stop
the spread of the disease
in the source material we learned the
army actually executed those trying to
leave
in an effort to contain the virus but
this of course
failed and it spread to the rest of the
world charles's story is actually how
the book opened
and this reordering adds a sort of
frantic feeling to the entry
as we learn that he escaped the base
that was the epicenter for the virus
dr ellis kind of walks in through what
happened and how deadly the virus
captain trips
is he explains that he basically wants
to track and trace all that came into
contact with campion
because of how lethal this thing is
ellis differs slightly from his book
counterpart
as does cobb because in that their names
were actually dr deninger and dr elder
not a massive change but i thought i
just pointed out because
hey we need to fill up time delta now he
wants to know why stu is immune
and says he will likely be the key to
finding the vaccine
but due to the intro we know that they
weren't that successful
a nurse comes in and sneezes and though
she says it's just allergies
we later learned that she tested
positive cut to harald riding through
the once vibrant beer to find it filled
with the dead
and completely deserted after spying on
franny
he fakes stumbling across her and the
story of soulmate begins
i'm just kidding but not really now it
turns out her dad died
and she's pretty much alone in this
world franny has hope that the disease
will fade away
and harold starts to spew the conspiracy
theories that was actually made in a lab
only thing is we we know that's actually
true here but branny obviously isn't too
happy with him
and fair enough because the dude's a bit
of a creep they go their separate ways
and harold ends up getting a gun from a
dead police officer
we never see him really use this again
but if you know the original work
you'll know that it pops up down the
line he was a spot in adler typewriter
and you may recognize this as being the
same one that jack used in the shining
to write his book
franny ends up burying her father in the
garden and we can also hear on the radio
what i think is brian cranston playing
the president
he denies the disease was manufactured
and tries to maintain order
but as we know from the book the us did
indeed create it
in the original work they actually
released it to other countries to avoid
blame
and this of course doomed the entire
planet now one of the more interesting
aspects of the entry is frannie's dream
in which he finds herself in a field
upon reaching a flattened patch of it
she comes across mother abigail played
by none other than whoopi goldberg
abigail is pretty much the manifestation
of good in this story
and she psychically reaches out to the
survivors in order to help them in a
fight against randall flagg
which we'll talk about in just a bit
after giving for any specific directions
harold ends up saving her life and we
watch as stu
is moved to the cdc by alice and dr cobb
doctor being in quotes because yeah not
a doctor
now this secure facility should keep
everyone safe but we watch ellis cough
and stu looks at him like when you're in
the supermarket and you clear your
throat
hey i've been there and i thought people
were genuinely gonna kill me
harold comforts franny who tried to take
her on life and in his mind this means
that she owes him something
and that her coming with him will be her
returning the favor
i don't want to get too far into the
spoilers just yet but this unrequited
love becomes
very important the further we get into
the story and it is important to pay
attention to it
we catch stew in a similar dream to
franny but here he comes across a white
wolf
which in the book is a representation of
randall flagg
alice and everyone at the base has come
down with captain trips
and he visits stew whilst coughing his
lungs up i actually
really like the character development
that alice got and he pretty much
symbolizes how the government made a
mistake
that they now massively regret however
he doesn't ever really apologize for it
but he wants to do one last good deed
for stew and save him from being locked
in the facility
instead of using a scalpel on himself he
gives it to stew to use his weapon on
cobb
who then arrives to kill him we learn
that cobb has been following contingency
plans to clean up the mess and that he
was going to kill stew
just to keep the secret about the cdc
cobb kills alice but stew manages to
stop him
before he does the same to him and he's
directed out the facility by general
starkey
who's completely sealed everything off
in the original work
this scene was slightly different and
stu had to do it without any help
we followed him as he tried to navigate
the almost alien environment
in order to escape starkey's role
differs too
as he was actually the person that
oversaw the base that developed captain
trips
and he spent a lot of his time
monitoring camera systems as the disease
spread
played by jk simmons the character
instantly leaves an impression
and he sits holding a gift from his
daughter who he learned died
starkey hadn't even opened it until he
heard the news
and the clasping onto this last bit of
humanity has made him realize that he
has to set stew free
so that some good can possibly come from
this he reads the poem the second coming
by william butler yeats
and this is actually about the book of
revelations namely the end of the world
in short the work predicts that no
matter what humanity will always come to
an
end and that civilization is doomed to
be undone
this was written after the first world
war which saw a massive amount of lives
lost
and here it feels very apt as we watch
similar circumstances happening
the poem also states that surely the
second coming will arrive
shortly and it references the bible
which becomes pivotal in the series
starkey takes his own life after reading
it
and stew makes it outside which is where
we cut defrani and harold
making their way out of town jump
forward five months later to the body
disposal unit
and we see harold without franny so now
know that something
or rather someone came between them with
his bird they talk about the movies
and harold admires how his friend is
able to let go of his past grudges
whilst he still holds on to his
humiliations
it's here that he's called you by the
wolf aka randall flag
and we see neon signs that are common in
las vegas which actually becomes a
prominent location in the work
rather than stepping away from the wolf
like studed harold approaches it
and it's here that he comes face to face
with randall we also hear this song the
stranger by billy joel in the background
and this is about changing to the point
that you don't recognize yourself
cut to harold doing the pointy tom
cruise fingers thing in the mirror
and it looks like he's changed his
personality to appear
more friendly and outgoing see this guy
would would never shout at someone on
set
he goes to meet fran and we see that
she's now showing but we don't know who
the dad is though
they do highly suggest that it's stew in
the book they met on the road
and harold became jealous over the pair
which made him completely resent him
he vows to kill them both and we flash
back to campion at the military base
which is where the virus is unleashed
this is what set
everything off and you may notice that a
fur actually held the door open for him
this is actually randall flag's foot and
he purposely wanted it to ravage the
world so that he could sneak in and take
over
randall is a supernatural being that we
catch hitchhiking
and he then appears in the back of the
car which is when we cut to the credits
randall is now instrumental to the
spread i loved watching him grinning in
the back seat
well aware of the hell he's about to
unleash now what an episode that was
and i really enjoyed this first entry in
the stand series
i feel like this is going to be
something special and i'd love to see
you back next week
as we go through it all but don't forget
that on the 30th of december we're
giving away three copies of the lord of
the rings 4k box set to our subscribers
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is to like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications
on and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode the links to our
socials are also in the description
and you can support the channel by
clicking the join button below and as a
thank you you get videos like this early
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the biggest
unanswered questions in tenet which will
be linked on screen now
we go over the most mysterious moments
in that movie to let you know what
actually happened
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you're still confused
anyway thank you for sitting through the
video i've been paul and i see you next
time
take care peace